hey guys welcome to my kitchen I'm
Justine you guys have been requesting a
new cooking video pretty much every time
I post a video that's not me cooking
this is all you want so to celebrate the
launch of the new iPhone 5s and 5c I'm
going to make an apple pie this isn't
gonna be just any apple pie the new
iPhone 5s comes in gold so I'm going to
attempt to make a gold apple pie or
something I'm not really sure what's
gonna happen so come along with me
friends for this ride
I've never made a pie I don't even own a
rolling pin I mean I bought a rolling
pin today time to cook
come along my friends time to cook I
feel like Walter White okay time to prep
for this apple pie got my recipe on my
iPad here I'm actually going to make the
pie crust myself from this box so I
almost bought a frozen one that I
thought you guys would yell at me please
don't yell at me for our ingredients
we're gonna need 6 cups of peeled apples
3/4 cups of sugar 2 tablespoons of
all-purpose flour it's all nutmeg lemon
juice cinnamon whatever you knew the
point oh I need my apron guess what I
ain't about measuring now we're ready to
cook I think I'm gonna make my pie crust
first so I mix half of a packet mixed
with me a whole packet Oh whole packet
probably pack at the whole packet
I hope this is big enough but it's all I
can find oh ma I need that box sir this
is my pot crust putting it in this
little mixture here smells like nothing
it smells like absolutely nothing 1/3
cup of cold water and some what about
that measuring life but knock - you're
not let's just make sure I put this in
there yes I do
stir it up what are you serving this
with looks like you're staring it with a
fork
perfect for no roll directions say blow
we're just rolling all that see me
rollin Hayden
y'all gonna catch me make enough I feel
like I should use my hands this is just
no I shouldn't I don't want to touch
this I'm stirring I was actually just
flattening this see me stir being really
excited about my rolling pin excited
don't worry I will be using this blender
so get your bodies ready for it shot too
soon
great so fresh so clean flattening fluff
I need floured surface look at my
surface and is so floured this is my
first rolling pin it's my very very own
should i I don't know what I'm doing
that has seen me roll in my eye
pie rolling looks so much easier when
Rachael Ray does it why can't I do this
you don't really fit so well it's good
enough right oh why don't you probably
bring it in my oven for 15 Oh save you
for later okay my crust is ready ovens
pre-meeting about to throw this in and
I'm gonna make my insides now six cups
of thinly sliced peeled apples hate
peeling apples so many more apples needs
to be cut okay how many apples six
whoops too little sideways yeah we're
gonna blend we're gonna blend will it
blend
Perceval this is gonna be the best apple
pie ever it's gonna taste like an iPhone
now that's gonna be so good
sugar 3/4 of a cup okay fine I may be
I'm measuring a little bit porn in one
test to test how many tips that looks to
be about a tablespoon I'm sorry do we
need some ground nutmeg here yes we do
sir
give you a little - say a little prick
for you
pulse oh no ya do it
guys we've got apple pie in here hey I
could make 45 minutes I have time for
that here it is
looks great it said to wait for this to
cool but I don't really want to wait I
think I might have a little too much
look at that look at this Apple I think
I have too many apples I'll just put
this aside I'm gonna roll up this little
top part
I need more flour want to make a real
nice real round should people do that
little pinchy thing on their pies I'm
gonna do a little pinchy thing little
pinchy sometimes see on pies there's
holes in them so I'm gonna put a few
holes cover edge of crust with 2 to 3
inches of wide strips of foil for the
first 15 to 20 minutes revenge excessive
browning I don't think I've used a pair
of scissors since I was 10 oh I have a
genius look at it you've got like a
little hat this is going in the
oven ok it's time to put his little hat
on burning burning myself I think it's
ready at least the timer went off oh my
god you're beautiful guys I think I did
something right I think I actually did
this right ok so this is supposed to be
a gold pie because I want it to be
representative of the new gold iPhone so
I bought some glitter stuff she put a
little glitter gel on our cake we're
going to take this glitter and just kind
of spread it all around like so
got some glitter gold we're gonna put a
lot on because I wanted to be real gold
how gold so gold I want it to be like 24
karat just a little decoration just to
be like hi I'm here that looks stupid
I'm covering up with gold let's just
dump this all on that how if I mix it
with this it now looks like sand I'm
really not sure what's happening here
hmm
don't have to do now oh that's just what
came out a lot quicker than I thought it
was going to hot quicker guys need to
stay out of the kitchen let's be real
let's be real real 5s thank you guys so
much for watching hope you enjoyed the
making of my iPhone 5s gold apple pie
I'd like to see the taste test upset
apple pie feel free to check the link in
the description or click on this
annotation you're taking right there